hi everybody it's a pleasure to welcome
you
to today's edition of the into the
impossible podcast
i am your fearful host brian keating and
today i'm talking to a friend
and an inspiration a fellow author a
scientist a collaborator
on the simon's observatory which i'm
privileged to play
a large role in and that is catherine
aka katie freeze
who is really an incomparable scientist
and that she's incredibly interested
both in theoretically understanding
models of how the universe began what
it's composed of how it's evolving
but also deeply invested in how you
could detect
evidence for or against her own pet
hypotheses
including things like in the
inflationary universe the origin of the
universe is postulated by
what is called natural inflation her
particular model of that
something called dark stars which are
stars made of dark matter
these are things that could be falsified
by evidence as katie describes in
today's podcast
i think it's really remarkable when we
think about someone like katie
who is as good at communicating the
excitement of her results to the public
as anybody i know but also at the
forefront
of research and leadership within
the scientific community and
specifically
within the field of cosmology that we
work on together
she's had a storied legendary career
you're going to learn
many things today including what it was
like to be a woman in
physics in the 1980s and and then
what it's like today how things have
improved her advice to young women
which i think also applies to young men
and even older men
like me as well you'll also hear about
why you should be very careful
in falling too much in love with your
own research
and why it is incredibly important to
even in these challenging times of covid
and other things
to maintain connections both to your
field and to the practitioners in your
field
i think that holds equally well whether
you're a cosmologist like katie
or whether you're working uh in an
office or maybe remotely in an office
stay up to date follow her advice stay
in touch
and enjoy cosmic cocktails whenever
possible and you'll hear about that
today
so sit back enjoy the ride into the
impossible with none other than the
effervescent
irrepressible indomitable incomparable
professor katie catherine freeze
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
[Music]
i'm speaking to catherine kd freeze
professor now
at the university of texas in austin
texas
she is known for many many things she is
currently the jeff and gail kadowski
endowed chair of physics she's known for
her work
in theoretical cosmology particle
physics and astrophysics
i want to give a warning to my audience
uh sometimes i i never dumped anything
down
but uh today i'm gonna go deep with
katie because
how often do i get a chance to talk this
oven as brilliant as the phenomenal
effervescent katie freeze katie how are
you doing today
oh brian thank you i'm i'm doing great
it's so much fun to talk to you you're
so kind so gracious you read my book
you even gave it an and comia on the
back saying
that it was at least barely readable but
i want you to know
that you were a great influence to me as
you are to many people not only for your
wonderful book the cosmic cocktail which
we'll be talking about today
subtitle three parts dark matter
but also in your role as a scientist
we're collaborators
and uh that makes me so happy that we
are finally collaborators a long time
career highlight unlocked to collaborate
with none other than katie freeze on the
simon's observatory
well yay brian thank you for for making
simon's observatory happen
it's a very cool thing yeah well a
little credit has to go to jim simons
but uh
obviously right now he's off the coast
of the galapagos islands so i doubt he's
tuning in
uh katie i wanna ask you what appeals to
you the most you've done writing
you've done uh uh popularizing of
science
if an alien wakes you up in the middle
of the night and says doctor professor
katie
who are you are you are you a mother
first are you a scientist
first how do you define yourself if you
give yourself
no room for preparation whoa well that
you definitely gave me no room for
preparation
well i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
to say more than one thing
so what i love most about my work is
research it's about creativity it's
about fun it's about collaboration
but i also have to say i'm a mother and
you can't beat that
so that's really up there yeah so and
then uh what do i what else do i do
a lot of sports so it's kind of a bigger
picture please
that's right well i always i do think of
you in all those different roles
i wonder do you know the etymology of
the word
matter okay something to do with the
greeks
it is from the greek it's actually from
the latin and it appeals
it actually includes what you just said
it means partially means
mother so it partially means it comes
from monterey
yes exactly and you are oh
yeah very interesting yeah i thought we
were
there so i do matter and matter
absolutely and i always think and
there's also the notion of mater
like alma mater is like soul mother
so i think of you as the sole mother of
modern day
dark matter and i want to talk to you
what transfixes you
what fascinates you about dark matter
the
well the most fascinating thing of all
of course is that we haven't yet
figured out what it is so it's a weird
universe
it's a cosmic cocktail it's if you take
everything we know about all the stuff
your you
your body the walls the book you wrote
the air around us the earth we're
sitting on
the sun that we depend on for the energy
all of that
everything is made of atoms as up to
only five percent of the universe
that's a pretty weird thing and so we
have to figure out what's the other 95
and that is terribly exciting
what do you say to those skeptics out
there we're living in kind of a
skeptical age
skepticism of experts skepticism even of
science itself
what do you say to a skeptic uh who says
provocatively
you know professor freeze how can you
speak so confidently about the past of
the universe
when you can't even tell me what 95 of
the universe is made up of how would you
answer such a skeptic
well the the amazing thing is the huge
amount of data that we have
that proves that we do understand a
tremendous amount about
the evolution of the universe so i would
actually
i when i think about it it's pretty
amazing because 100 years ago
we knew almost nothing and
since the time of albert einstein since
the development of general relativity
the progress has just been breathtaking
and
accelerating i'm not talking about the
accelerating universe i'm talking about
the accelerating knowledge
of what we've what we've learned so
throughout
history there have been creation myths
people want to understand what's around
us and why and
and where we go and so on and so forth
and
well we had one called pretty soon after
einstein wrote down his equations other
people applied them
to the universe as a whole and came up
with this notion
of uh well the universe could be
expanding contracting static
but that so 1915 einstein 1929
edwin hubble proved that the universe is
expanding and
this is so anyway back on creation myth
we have one called the hot big bang but
guess what it's not a myth it's right
it's incomplete as can be but
it is just amazing to think in 100 years
how much we know
yeah when i talked to people recently i
had on
uh sir roger penrose after he won the
nobel prize we'll get into the nobel
prize with your permission later on but
i had on frank wilcek also recently and
i keep talking about this notion that
you know the science is settled
but only when you look back in reverse
so to speak you make a very convincing
case
that we do understand a tremendous
amount about the creation myth as you
just called it
the hot big bang model pioneered in in
large part by people that you've worked
with and that you
yourself have contributed to over the
last you know a few decades
but uh but if you look in reverse we do
understand a lot only you know back to
the first three minutes but the question
i always have
and i always receive you know what came
before that and how much confidence can
you have in that
as you know many people have come up
including sir roger penrose with
alternative
actual origins you know when the
universe comes into and out of existence
after these
eons as he calls them or our friend paul
steinhardt
who has a model where the universe
cycles into and out of existence
but i always point out they always have
to have basically a hot big bang within
them somewhere would you agree with that
well the the data go back to
14 billion years ago and we've just
nailed that there's no
there's no doubt about it but then if
you if you just no matter how far back
you go you can keep
trying to go farther back and that is of
course what we do by the way i have some
theories too i have one called the
phantom balance which i'm happy to tell
you about oh yeah no please let's let's
go into it that's that's nice
it's a universe that well bouncing in
the sense
that it reaches a maximum size and then
it recollapses
and it keeps doing that and it's driven
at the final stages not now but down the
road by a phantom energy
which means it's a dark energy of a very
very peculiar properties that is
even able to rip apart black holes
so that allows this universe because
normally if you try to do a cyclic
universe like that
the black holes eventually eat it up but
if you have this phantom energy that
doesn't happen but we also can't live
with the ordinary
einstein's equations we have to modify
them and that was something that i was
playing around with anyway the idea that
extra dimensions in the universe can
give you these modified equations
and so that so you know we need to um i
don't like calling them tooth fairies
but we need this phantom energy and we
need this
uh this is modified equations and we
don't know if that's right so
one of the fun things about the research
that i do
is that we invent stuff mostly it's
gonna turn out to be science fiction but
you know what
every now and then it's right and then
and then you do get a nobel prize
so you've got to try everything you can
and that is just it's really really fun
but as you said you know that you know
what the big underlying problem is that
all of these models they all
have to deal with the question of time
the arrow of time
so in writing down relativistic
equations we treat
space and time as being some being
unified although there's a minus sign in
front of the time where there's a plus
sign in front of the space
but we don't understand time and
i don't think anybody has a clue at the
moment but someday
that is the big one yeah you're i was
talking with frank wilczyk who is i know
a friend of yours
um and uh he has a very simple
definition of time
at least in one sense but in other sense
it's incredibly complex and he says time
is what clocks measure and
clocks are anything that change so in
principle
the universe can be a clock our bodies
can be a clock our hearts are clocks
and he talks about the speed of thought
like how many thoughts will you have
in a lifetime how many heartbeats will
you have in a lifetime well you can
basically
uh quantify those but yes what about the
psychological clock which as you know
doesn't necessarily correspond with the
clock on your microwave
that's right yeah and this notion of
of you know and then complementarity
with frequency and time being
interrelated you know can you have
a clock where it only changes once or as
i've asked uh
sir roger penrose and hi and uh his
collaborator late collaborator stephen
hawking
i never asked him this but in a brief
history of time
i was really startled to learn that uh
that that was really written in the
sense to
to kind of bolster the theory that he
came up with
this is hawking and hartle jim hartel at
santa barbara
where i know you've had a um you have a
visiting appointment or you're on the
board of the kavli
institute for i was also a postdoc there
oh that's right yeah
well i got to know and jim hartle was a
faculty member in chicago while i was a
grad student so yeah
oh that's right and so we had this uh
conversation you know what is the
what was the reason that that stephen
hawking wrote a brief history of time
and then why did he have to write
another book called
a briefer history of time and i think
that really signifies what you just said
there's so many different definitions
some have better qualities than others
for different purposes
but it is in fact a relative kind of
existence but
i want to get into something specific
with you i think of you when if
an alien wakes me up and says who is
katie freeze not that you care
but i think of incredible creativity i
think of a type of wisdom and creativity
mixed together that make you unique
and you're known for many things you
just talked about a new idea this
phantom
bounce you're also known of something
kind of mysterious
uh called a dark star can we talk a
little bit about your your concept of a
dark star that you created
okay so i was so so yeah this one is
testable this one's going to be tested
so
i always like that i like to i like you
know i do a lot of different things i
work
as you said on the beginnings of the
universe i work on dark matter but in
the end if you contest it that makes me
really really happy which by the way is
why i joined the simon's observatory
but anyway so dark stars so
it the very first stars to form in the
history of the universe and that was
200 million years after the big bang
mind you we are now 14 billion years out
so that's
pretty early on i'm trying not to say
pretty damn early on
but anyway so don't worry you can't
possibly curse more than ray weiss did
on the show we we'll edit it out
okay so anyway so the first stars to
form in the history of the universe 200
million years after the big bang very
very early on
they were well they are not like the
ones that we have today
so they formed inside of proto galaxies
little smaller things that are million
times smaller than today's galaxies
and in the middle there you have a
collapsing cloud
of hydrogen gas and helium
and that is all there is in the universe
at that point because the other elements
haven't been made yet
so with in this collapsing as this
collapsing cloud gets denser and denser
and denser
it is at the center of these
proto-galaxy so it pulls in more and
more dark matter and that dark matter
ends up providing a heat source
so that if the dark matter is made of a
particular type of particle the weakly
interacting
massive particle then those particles
are their own antimatter
and when they annihilate with one
another those annihilation products get
stuck inside this collapsing cloud they
heat it up
and well they provide a heat source for
this really really big bright thing so
we called them dark stars before we knew
how big and bright they were going to be
and uh of course you've not only you
know inspired different ways to
think about them theoretically i want to
actually let's go there now katie you
have a very interesting
conjecture i think you did it with my
good friend david spurgle
and you talk about it in the cosmic
cocktail and that's for a dna
dark matter detector i just couldn't
stop thinking about this as an
experimentalist
and i'm a deeply closeted theoretical
cosmologist too so i
i take inspiration wherever i can get
can you talk to about
talk to us a little bit first of all
katie how do you work what's your
work style do you do you have a way that
you can teach the audience
members of this uh into the impossible
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
podcast how can you help us improve our
creativity in our imagination
and then how do you do it how do you
come up with so many ideas
and uh and keep the creative juices
flowing
oh wow well that's a i mean it's not
something you control
having an idea but you can put yourself
in a good setting for where it might
happen
so i mean one one
one thing that i do is when when you
hear about new results so then i start
reading the papers around them
and then i think well yeah but why
didn't they do this or
um oh my gosh this is an ingredient that
we could use to do
something else and so you just ideas
kind of just pop in your head but you
obviously have to
know what's going on around you in terms
of the research and what other people
are doing and then
also i was i remember i was at a
conference where people were talking
about
um very very early on about dark energy
very a bunch of us were the hallway very
frustrating because we thought
people are too narrow-minded in the way
they're looking at this and so then
i don't know i just was uh and then boom
i had an idea you know
so and then in the middle i remember in
the conference looking back at the other
two
uh and they're looking within what
so and so you so if if you're really
really
busy during the semester teaching and
taking care of students
it's not going to happen so you have to
have that time
to breathe and and
allow the juices to flow and i'll tell
you the only other place that happens is
in the bathtub
like archimedes like archimedes by the
way
true katie jim simons has a yacht that
he is currently sailing on
off the coast of the galapagos islands
and it's called
the archimedes oh okay i love that
yeah yeah so that says you're in good
company with jim simons archimedes and
many other people i actually heard that
from i was reading oh avi loeb i'm
reading his book
about uh umura mura the uh which he
claims is an extraterrestrial spacecraft
visiting our solar system from perhaps a
distant solar system
launched many years ago he'll be on the
podcast next month to talk about that so
stay tuned everybody if you're listening
out there
uh do me a favor give a thumbs up to
this on youtube
or uh give a review on itunes mention
what you're learning from katy freeze
because
i learn a lot and i still feel like the
only trait that i have is this
relentless passion for
for learning and learning feels good
katie i actually had
a psychologist on the show he gave me
some free therapy he's a famous
psychologist at brown university my alma
mater
and he says that curiosity can be used
to break bad habits so if you smoke or
if you overeat like i do
you can actually use the curiosity why
am i hungry am i really hungry did i not
eat am i just emotionally eating
and so he said curiosity can actually
help you break
addictions because your mind is addicted
to learning
and i feel like my audience is like that
i i see a lot of
i don't see any bad addictions in your
except the cocktail talk to us about
uh the you know are we going to become
alcoholics if we read this book katie
well uh i have to tell you that you
asked me where another place where ideas
where ideas happen okay so there are the
ones that i have by myself but then
a lot of a lot of them are collaborative
so this is the
this is the most fun part of my job so i
have friends that i like to work with
and they're also
really fun silly creative people and we
sit down and we
we start we just start talking about
what
some problem that everybody's trying to
solve or whatever and then
oh it's and most and then you write down
on the back of the envelope
if you try to figure it out and you
realize that's not going to work it's
not going to work it's not going to work
which is by the way the thing about dark
stars
it took us it was that was kind of
frustrating it took us a long time to
come up with that idea and then another
year to realize
that they're actually stars that shine
you know but uh
so where was i going with this but that
was a totally collect fun collaborative
effort and
and i had to learn really kind of a
whole new field because i didn't know
too much about stars you know so that
was that was really really fun where was
i going with this what question did you
think i was asking about the dna dark
matter detector at this point
well you're asking about the cosmic
cocktail oh oh yeah sorry
so wait i was going to tell you about
the role of of cocktails
so well believe it or not that's where
some of these ideas
do that's where they happen because we
all get together relax and have a few
drinks and that's and that's when things
happen and so one of them is
um andrei droukier is this is my crazy
polish collaborator who speaks english
french german and polish all at the same
time and
and i so i met him when i was a postdoc
at harvard and we were at
a conference in jerusalem and he knew
where to go for the new year's parties
a place called cinema tech so
and then he started telling me about the
work he'd done on
detecting neutrinos on ideas for
detecting neutrinos
and then we decided oh yes let's we
would apply this to wimps
and so goodman and wrote the first paper
but then
i got andre to come up to harvard and
work with me and david spurgle okay
that's where this
collaboration initially started and so
we wrote the
pioneering the first the very earliest
papers that calculated well
what what people could see if they were
to look for these things and then we got
this whole field going
experiments all over the world and
that's a lot of what i'm describing in
in the book
and and now fast forward
20 years and i'm going to answer your
question about dna dark matter detectors
so the the base the idea here
is with with the same collaborators the
idea is that you have
a nanometer thin layer
of gold okay gold atoms and
that means like it's one atom thick
attached to that believe it or not
are strands hanging strands of dna
and you can buy this from illumina inc
it's in san diego a san diego company
or 200 bucks and i don't remember
why they constructed these things but uh
it's useful anyway so so you can buy
these things of course the ones you buy
off the shelf or not
are too radioactive you have to get
cleaner ones the ideas is that you
when you have a the wimps wimp particles
the dark matter particles come along
they hit the gold knock a gold nucleus
forward into these hanging strands of
dna
and then the gold breaks the the
dna so the beautiful thing about dna is
you can control
exactly what's hanging there so you can
control
um the different the adenine guanine
thymine the different bases you control
exactly where it is and so therefore you
can go identify exactly where the break
happened so you can figure out exactly
what path
the goal took as it went through the dna
and by figuring out the path of the gold
you can go back and figure out the path
of the dark matter
that hit the gold in the first place so
that's the idea oh wow
and so has anyone tried to implement
this at a large enough scale or are they
no just um so far small
prototype tests so george church
is a famous geneticist and he
has he has a small i mean we're not
going to actually use gold
because that would get too expensive to
have that much gold but so
so the dna strands and you have to have
them hanging straight so he's put them
in a centrifuge and
and that makes them stick out and so
he's done some preliminary tests
so that's as far as it's gotten and
yeah we uh we need to go further with it
uh so another thing that that i've been
really fascinated to see is
uh your journey uh in the field
obviously you did
uh incredible research uh very early on
and you continue to do so
but it's also the inspiration that you
have for your many students and proteges
uh yeah i consider myself an informal
student of yours but you've had people i
i think i think jenna levin was was
janna one of your
janet jan 11 was my very first graduate
student i was an assistant professor at
mit
she's been a frequent guest she's been
on my show three times already just this
year
she's wonderful she is she also has this
freeze
gene which is very creative and she
comes up with new ideas
to test things that may or may not be
visible and of course i'm interested in
what making the
you know invisible visible as galileo
said i think i have a little
uh caricature of him somewhere around
here on my desk i've got here's marie
curie
here's a little sock puppet i can i got
for for the holidays um i'm looking for
i've got galileo back here somewhere but
she also uh is very interested
in in making uh making new ideas visible
as galileo's once said and i wonder you
know when you're working with a student
how is being a mentor to a graduate
student similar
or different and different from being a
parent to your biological children say
thank you for listening to the into the
impossible podcast or watching it on
youtube
as you know doctors recommend to stretch
your fingers at regular intervals so as
not to get
any possible signs or symptoms of
carpal tunnel syndrome we have enough to
worry about with all sorts of other
pandemics running around the world so
exercise your fingers frequently
by tapping the subscribe like and rating
buttons wherever you're listening to
this
i read each and every bit of feedback
uh this this past week i read a feedback
that
compared this podcast to lex friedman's
podcast to
uh to eric weinstein's podcast it really
fills me with
tremendous joy i'm doing this really
because i get to talk to people like
today's wonderful guest katie freeze
so i'm enjoying it help me enjoy it even
more
uh do your bit it doesn't cost much and
in return you might
uh you might be surprised to find out
who you're impelling me
to invite on the arthur c clarke center
for human imaginations into the
impossible podcast
please take this moment to like
subscribe and
leave a comment wherever you can
i don't yell at my grad students as
often
[Laughter]
at least i hope not oh
yeah um i yeah i care about them a lot
i want them to do well you know i can
actually when they first start out if
they need me to be tough on them i'll do
it
and i do it right away so that if
if i feel they're that they have a
weakness i'll tell them
and in the end they're grateful for that
but i think one of the things david
spergel said that really
really reflected that i reflected on a
lot is if you want student
the thing that makes students do well is
love that you really really care
and and so that's that's what i try to
do
and i also try to get them to think
well that's what look when a student
first does their first project
they they're they just do something
simple it's actually not easy to come up
with a simple project that has a
guaranteed paper at the end of it okay
so that's a really tough thing to do but
you do that and then in the course of
that
you hope that they'll say oh yeah but
what about so and so then you'll say yes
do that yes excellent and the other
thing i try to do is introduce them to
lots and lots of people
so they can network and learn from other
people especially because you know i
have this giant
group in sweden of all things so i uh
the swedish research council gave me a
very generous grant
15 million over 10 years and that means
i have a very large group in sweden i
spend half of the year there well not
now because it covered but
and so they they they have each not only
each other but the visitors coming
through and
i think that interaction oh and i bring
them to the us
to interact with people and you know in
the us as well and so the networking
they get that
is one of the best things i can offer
them yeah okay that's a longer answer i
had to think it through i guess but no
that's fine yeah it's a little bit uh
at a level you know i have to brian can
i take can i take charge for a minute of
course
can i tell you about my background yes i
want to hear about it
okay this is the milky way
so at the same time you get so far away
to take a selfie
yeah yeah well at the center is the
supermassive black hole that was the
reason for a nobel prize for two of our
winners this
this year and then
as you move away from the black hole you
see this this pinwheel the spiral
structure
that's where the stars are that's where
the sun is and no that's not getting
sucked into the black hole
and that is where the atomic matter is
it's called the disk of the galaxy but
that ain't nothing
what about all this stuff out here
that's the dark matter
and the dark matter does not have this
many stars that's just because it's
prettier to have a few stars out there
but you know what there really aren't
very many
and but we know it's there you can see
it pulling on things it's move it's it's
uh
it's pulling on stars it's pulling on
gas it's pulling on light it lenses
light that comes by so you know it's
there
and that's what we have to figure out
what it is
so i had to show you my background very
much related to my work that's
background you won't find on wikipedia
and actually one thing that you did
very uh very uh significantly
is you ruled out a particular type of
candidate
that is actually literally close to
where i am right now at uc san diego one
of my colleagues uh kim greist
came up with the name macho back in the
80s i believe it stood for massive
compact halo objects and you played a
role
in kind of uh not not out of any
personal animosity
but your work basically in part led to
the the killing of the macho can you
talk a little bit about what that's like
and why you were motivated to maybe
investigate alternatives to machos
okay so you do realize we're talking
here about the machos versus the wimps
don't you gotta love it and and i'm i
don't know if i'm sorry to say but the
wimps have won
so at one conference somebody came up to
me afterwards and said
i have a wimp yes anyway
so um well the the
the question at the time was as you go
to lower and lower mass stars
there you know there's 20 there's ones
that weigh 10 times as much as the sun
but as you get to a tenth of the mass of
the sun as well
there's more and more of them and what
if there are just
we call it dark matter because because
we can't see it it's dark but what if
it is stars it's just they're so faint
that we couldn't see them
or you go even lower mass you go below
about a tenth of the mass of the sun and
then you have this a lot of the same
physics going on inside the inside the
objects but
they cannot burn uh they cannot
burn hydrogen so they they don't shine
so they still exist but they just don't
shine so we call them substellar objects
so the question was well other tons
of low mass stars or substellar objects
and that was a very reasonable
explanation
i remember martin reese coming to one of
my talks saying hey
hey you haven't mentioned this
possibility and i thought okay well
let's look at that
and those are the things that are machos
and so we looked at a bunch of
a combination of data including hubble
space telescope for the substellar
objects it can only be a few percent of
the galaxy
so because hubble could actually see
them or then you go to lower mass
and these things we use we use a
combination of theory and experiment
to show that nope that's not going to
cut it either that there's
you can't have very many of these things
and in fact now there's a mystery that
even the numbers that we
we predicted as a you know as an upper
bound there aren't enough
so therefore now they do find them and
they shine very very faintly as well
and there's not enough of them so that
just it didn't cut it so the only thing
the other option would be for machos
would be stellar remnants in other words
when stars run out of fuel then they
collapse become very dense
the sun will become a white dwarf one
day or
neutron stars or black holes
for the very heavy ones and it's still
possible that
so we looked at that also combination of
theory and experiment and
you could have some percent of the dark
matter in the form of white dwarfs
but it just it didn't work so
machos are dead that's really looking
for wimps
all right kim grice does not hold a
grudge by the way he is
all for the truth um i want to switch
now a different
direction and talk about uh talk about
women in science and you have said uh
quote you were forced to be a
trailblazer in the field
of astrophysics and cosmology you never
wanted to but things are definitely
improving can you talk about uh what
physics was like as a as a woman
uh maybe when you started your career
versus where it is now
you know what i found yesterday a
picture from
my undergraduate physics class okay so
there were 40 physics made this is
princeton and there were 46
there's usually 20 physics majors our
class was very weird at 40.
now let's see if you can find the women
i think i see
number 17 yeah that's me
and alice ruse and that's it that's it
yeah
so so you know and the thing is i went
to a high school which didn't have any
physics and so there i actually went to
mit as a freshman
and there were all these kids who went
to bronx high school science and da da
da da
and the people talk about the climate
problems of physics well one of them is
that
i think the boys as well as the girls
are very nervous and they're they're
thinking oh my god i might not be smart
enough to be here and so they
they talk each other down and they say
this is easy
this is trivial this is freshman physics
you know what freshman physics is
phenomenally difficult stuff it's
all it's hundreds of years worth of
stuff that's all taught in one semester
or one year it's ridiculous and so
by the end i went to mit when i was 16
because you know what i actually am
pretty smart
but at the end of freshman year i
thought i was dumb yeah
so yeah it was really it was really
tough it was really really tough
you know speaking of that i had on mit
professor ray weiss i don't know if you
ever encountered him
yes i'm friends with right because i was
an assistant professor at mit too later
you know i didn't know that but yeah i
talked to ray and i talked to him i've
been asking
all the nobel prize winners that come on
my show i asked them do you ever
experience the imposter syndrome
uh because as you say you know it's like
freshman physics is really hard because
you're getting 700 years worth you know
from
pre kepler to uh up until you know the
large hadron collider
all in one all in one semester and
all these nobel laureates are telling me
that they experienced it at least the
experimentalist
seemed to say it barry barrish was the
one who alerted me to this
he said i still have the imposter
syndrome
and i said are you kidding me you won
the nobel prize like how could you
possibly do it he said no the nobel
prize made it worse
because when he went up to get his medal
he left it in my office by the way
that's where i got the actual no i'm
just kidding that's a piece of chocolate
that i probably did
oh wait let me go get mine i have a
bunch too okay
i'm gonna visit you and eat them out of
your house and home um so when he went
to go
collect his award he said uh barry told
me that he had to sign this
log that testified that he took delivery
of the medal
and then he got his check unlike you
know bob dylan who didn't show up for
months and months to get his nobel prize
in literature
uh but when he opened this book the
ledger
that has the list of all these nobel
prize signatories he saw this guy's
signature
albert einstein and he said he got
tingle i'm getting chills now we're
recollecting this and
and so did ray weiss and and then i
asked another
mit professor uh who won the nobel prize
said frank wilcheck
did you ever experience the imposter
syndrome he said oh no
quite the opposite not that he's being
arrogant but that he
felt like he was told since he was 22
years old
that asymptotic freedom would lead to an
eventual nobel prize
which he didn't win for 31 years so
imagine the excruciating horror of it
you know i've heard stories that in the
future we'll be able to take a pill
and then we'll live forever and uh we
won't we'll cure all disease
let's hope that comes someday but you
won't cure accidents in other words you
could still die
so you'd have this horrible anxiety
never go out of your house because you
might get into a car accident you know
why would you ever leave if you could
just
live forever and i felt like that was
probably like frank
you know for 30 years he just had to
stay alive of course he kept very busy
inventing different dark matter
candidates one of which you had a played
a big role in which is the axion
uh if you had to put your money on a
dark matter candidate
uh what would you put that uh on if you
had to make a bet like stephen hawking
uh we'll change the stakes of the bet we
won't bet a pornographic magazine
but but instead what would you bet the
dark matter candidate is
so you know i've never been willing to
do that because what's the point i mean
nature is what nature
is and i don't my best my hopes
do not equal the the truth the truth is
what it is so i don't
but what what do i think is the best
motivated i think the wimps and axions
are the best motivated i think
because they're not we didn't make them
up just to solve the dark matter problem
which is what a lot of these new things
are they're only there for solving dark
matter that doesn't cut it in my opinion
i think there has to be more
it has to do more than that and so
maxions are well motivated so
that's why i by the way frank franklin
chick and i do have a vet
oh you do yeah we have a bet because
so you know there so there's this dhamma
data this italian food
that has hints of dark matter
based on annual modulation meaning the
fact that signal goes up and down with
the time of year as the earth goes
around the sun which is by the way our
idea that was davidsburg laundry
and i thought of that so i am highly
motivated to want that to be correct but
i don't
i don't think that way but but you know
when they first came out with it 20
years ago or whatever
at this point that sounded like a bunch
of nonsense but at this point there is
no
alternate explanation there's no single
background explanation
so i really do want to know what they're
seeing and there are other experiments
made now made of the same material that
are testing it and so we will know
within five years
and so frank and i had to bet that
within five years
he bet is going to be ruled out and i
bet that it's not
and that was problem i think it was two
years ago now
okay and so what did he bet i think
oh it was it was extreme like he he he
loses a thousand if i win and he use i
lose one if he wins or something
wow
too bad you didn't bet one to a thousand
bitcoin that would be pretty good
uh but yeah in his previous book uh he's
got a new book called fundamentals
coming out but his previous book called
a beautiful question which was written
in i believe 2015
he says that uh supersymmetry or
evidence for supersymmetry will be found
at the lhc within five years
so he's got i think he's got one year
left on that i wish i could have bet him
on that
because i don't see particular evidence
for super symmetry
yeah that would be so great that's sad i
want to go back to dhamma but only
sort of tangentially first of all i mean
it is being conducted by eminent
scientists one of whom you
quote in the book uh rita burnett
burnaby
and then she is pictured alongside a
frequent guest on the into the
impossible podcast
my friend elena april at columbia
university
and they're kind of diametrically
opposed but first i want to ask you
why are so many women attracted to dark
matter is it is
i've got elena you got rita we have vera
rubin obviously there's
you janet levin what what is it about is
it
what is what does the dark matter
community doing right that other
aspects of physics could perhaps learn
from you know when i started to write
the book i wanted to write about the
science and i also realized i want to
convey the excitement of doing science
so it's kind of part memoir part science
you know
but then as i was writing it and i kept
featuring women i'm like oh wow i get to
show pictures of all these cool women
doing cool stuff
and maybe young women will get inspired
and think oh i can do this too you know
and then so i started asking well why
are there so many more women in dark
matter and i think one of the reasons
is that it's you can still do small
experiments on the experimental side
that one person can run a group
starting out with you know 10 or 20 or
whatever maybe it'll grow bigger in the
end to 100 but it's a small group and so
you can
you can do it without too much of this
kind of
macrodynamics that we were talking about
earlier that you you can be the one in
charge
and so maybe maybe that's the reason but
i don't really know yeah i don't know
well one woman who's playing a role in a
huge experiment is of course fabiola
giannatti
i thought of her as the counter example
it's okay there's also a lot of italians
there's there are a lot of italians
in cosmology men and women and
especially more women than
in the u.s now one of the problems the
u.s had and that we're thinking you
asked me about being a woman in physics
but things have drastically improved is
that
i was told by the chairman i i had it i
arrived pregnant at mit
i mean you don't do that they haven't
been that before okay
nobody yeah i would never do that there
aren't a lot of women in faculty to
begin with when you show up like this
and they actually changed the rules
there was no maternity leave
and they even changed the rules on the
sloan fellowship that you were not
allowed to use it to take time off
from teaching even though the person
before me that's what he'd done but they
made sure i couldn't you know
and so i that was that was really tough
and
you know we didn't and also the so child
care we could barely find any i mean it
was just it was torture and then my my
husband was a postdoc
at harvard and the entire salary went to
child care
but frankly i think that's why we're
divorced because that was a
torture torture situation nowadays
pretty much every university has at
least minimal maternity leave and for
those who don't want to call it
maternity leave
they they have a semester off for all
junior faculty or something i don't care
i got paternity leave effectively you
know oh
god brian like they couldn't even give
me once they said it was a benefit mit
could not afford to even give me one
semester off oh poor mit
you know their 20 billion dollar
endowment yeah i believe them
you have a party to leave oh i think
that's fabulous yeah i did
i'm trying to maximize it i'm trying to
encourage my wife to have more
kids i was gonna say how many kids do
you have just
just just just a handful literally um
yeah no it's it's it's amazing i love it
i would love to have more but you know
my role is a lot more
limited and time deranged at least than
than my wife
uh i want to close out by by just
reflecting back on dhamma
not necessarily you know to criticize it
or anything but to say
it's it's unique at least as far as i'm
concerned
that an experiment led by eminent
scientists
from around the world conducts an
experiment for you know almost
30 years now acquires data at the you
know
you know 20 sigma level and it's not
even that they're not
that they're dismissed or so they're
they're almost taken at a level of
crackpots in some ways and
and i i find that very surprising to me
because
there are a lot i just we just featured
one of our collaborators uh i won't say
you know who would actually i can say
ichiro kamatsu is a friend of ours
you know he just got a tremendous amount
of attention for publishing a result
that was 2.4 sigma
by the way so that's one of the papers
when you're asking about creativity i
started thinking about that so i have an
idea
so my [ __ ] and i are thinking about it
i'm not telling you
you can't you can't tease it like that
katie that's not fair come on give me an
exclusive scoop
ideas don't work nine out of ten don't
work and that's what i want to
if it works i'll tell you all right come
back on all right you heard it here
katie commits or else she gets to pay me
a thousand bitcoin
so katie i've heard uh with regard to
dhamma that one of the reasons that
people
don't trust a result which is otherwise
at a putatively very high level of
confidence
much higher than even the higgs was
claimed detected evidence for
in 2012 that that they won't share their
data
when you as a theorist experience those
kinds of situations
does that naturally cause you to have a
prejudice against
accepting those data or is it just
against the scientific method and we
should
we should be more um forthright with our
data i mean we i'm guilty of that too i
haven't always shared all my data
because it takes a lot of time to put
into a into a not that you can't
understand it
but there's a lot of you know dirty
laundry in the sense of
well this is how we calibrate but then
we have a glitch and there's a lot of
kind of massaging that we do especially
with low count data
but in there do you think they could
just uh rehabilitate that
result by making it making their data
public essentially
so yes they should have made it public a
long time ago they've had plenty of
times
as you said to massage it okay so this
it's very unusual and
we don't understand why they don't the
the other reason
so i'll tell you some of the pros and
cons one of the other problems is
it's the only experiment that sees
anything so
the other experiments such as xenon or
lux these
large vats of xenon they they have only
null results they see nothing
but now the question is how do you
compare dama which is made of sodium
iodide
and xenon which is made of xenon and
in order to do that that's where the
theorists come in so if you take a
certain
a particular type of theory you can make
a comparison
and in this in the vanilla model you see
what you find is that
the xenon negative results actually rule
out the dhamma
interpret interpretation in terms of
dark matter however
you've just compared apples and oranges
so that's a very dangerous thing to do
so the beauty is so you know when i
finally got really interested
when frank caliprist of princeton who's
very very careful
extremely precision measurement kind of
guy said to me you know we have to go
test this dharma experiment and i
thought oh my god
so he started working on him he started
the saber experiment these are people
oh the the other thing is that dhamma
won't let anybody
else buy crystals from the same vendor
so nobody
else could get the sodium iodine well
guess what now three different groups
have made their own sodium iodide
crystals
and so one of the experiments coastline
100 is running
so they'll know in a few years so we
don't have to speculate anymore no more
theory required to compare xenon versus
nothing it's just going to be either
right or wrong which is the origin of
the bit i have this right will check
and and the other thing is that the
reason that you have to take down
seriously when they first came out with
it people said oh it's radon
it's atmospheric muons it's ten
explanations for what they're seeing
guess what it's not any of those things
they've all been ruled out they can't be
right
and here's another weird thing they're
sitting right next to xenon in the same
laboratory on the ground
outside of rome and xenon does not see
so if it's some kind of junk
that is infecting dhamma well then xenon
should have the same junk and it doesn't
yeah so what's name that's why i'm
really excited to hear
these results from cosine 100. yeah and
if they could do an experiment in the
southern hemisphere that would be
interesting to me too
what's going to happen too that's where
this uh saber is going to be in
australia
oh is that right okay fantastic okay
katie well we're reaching the end of the
time that you have
you're so gracious with your time and
your attention i want to
ask you uh if you're willing to go into
the impossible and discuss the final
three questions
that i ask all of my guests on the into
the impossible podcast
the first one has to do with looking
into the future
not about your material will but as you
know alfred nobel
endowed a nobel medallion plus some
money but he had no wife no children
uh no direct relatives at all so he
endowed an ethical will
that he said his prizes must go to those
who have made humankind better and
in that vein i want to ask you what kind
of ethical
or knowledge or wisdom would you most
want to leave not for your
material will but for your ethical will
for people
like me who are influenced with uh from
by you and
want to learn from you outside of what
you do in the laboratory
so i thought about that and the message
i would like to send is to
young women i would like to tell them
don't
if don't worry about the imposter
syndrome
because don't think that you're dumber
than you are
believe in yourself you have a passion
for something
go and do it so so i guess that would
that would be my message and the other
thing would be
you can have it all so brian you asked
me at the beginning how do i define
myself and i didn't give a unique
definition in terms of one thing i said
i have
i'm a mater a mother and i work on matar
i'm a physicist and you didn't ask me
about all the sports i do
you can have as a you can be a woman in
physics and have a
wonderful life using your mind with
other really fun
people and so that's that's those are my
words
to the future very nice that's very nice
okay the next question has to do also
with the future and it's either related
if you want to
this monolith that appears in arthur c
clarke's
2001 a space odyssey where these
primates come upon this monolith in the
savannah of africa and they don't know
what to do with it
and then the monolith appears again on
the moon when humanity is advanced
technologically to the point
it could actually interact with this and
i'm reminded of richard feynman he had
this famous cataclysm
question he said if in some cataclysm
all scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed
and only one sentence left to capture
everything that humanity had learned
about the universe
what information what statement would
contain the most information
in the fewest possible words and he had
the atomic hypothesis
but i want to ask you what is katie
freeze if you had to summarize
on a monolith that would last a billion
years uh what would you put on such a
monolith
so first of all i have to point out we
missed our chance there was a model in
utah
so i what what i would i would put on
the model is a
an something about okay on the monolith
i would write about the big bang so 14
billion years ago the universe started
out hot
densely packed full of tiny subatomic
particles
that are the fundable fundamental
constituents of all matter
then the universe expanded and cooled to
allow matter to collapse into galaxies
stars to form and life to exist
so we understand the past now you go
figure out the future
very good and then the last question
that i ask
all my guests now we're going to go
backwards in time and ask for some
advice
to your former self and that's related
to the title of this podcast
as you may know arthur c clarke had many
different sayings the one is very famous
we opened the podcast
with him saying it in his actual voice
the uh
only any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
his second law states that for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert
and his third law is the only way of
discovering
the limits of the possible is to venture
a little way past them
into the impossible and that's the
origin of the name of my podcast
so i want to ask you what aspect of life
was mysterious to a 20 year old or 30
year old
catherine freeze but now makes sense
because you had the courage to go
into the impossible so i have to tell
you when i was in college
i really underestimated the fields of
relativity and cosmology i thought that
they were
they were popular with the public mostly
science fiction
not not the real deal not serious
subjects of attention so then
somewhere along it's somewhere line so i
started out actually doing a very
different field of physics and then
somewhere along the lines i heard about
big bang nuclear synthesis
three minutes after the big bang
predictions of elements over 10 orders
of magnitude that are correct
what we understand the universe three
minutes after the big bang
well that ain't nothing i start at that
point i'm like i gotta learn more
and i had my mentor david schramm that i
read that i met
who taught cosmology and so all this my
life changed
so i have learned to appreciate
and of course work in some of the most
exciting topics
that humans could possibly imagine so
don't underestimate
what's when when you hear about things
when you're that that
uh go find out and i found out that
cosmology is the coolest field on earth
or in space well katie freeze author
of the cosmic cocktail three parts dark
matter
i can't wait till we can have a cocktail
together last time we had a drink
together
was at the university of pennsylvania
where we gave a a public lecture to
the audience and you signed some books
and you signed my other copy i bought
this copy and then you gave me a copy
and we did a book swap
i want to thank you for uh for all the
kindness that you've shown me personally
with my book with research being a part
of the simon's observatory
bringing in those young people from
sweden and from elsewhere from michigan
from texas now uh you're really an
inspiration you're a mentor and a role
model not just for women
for men for women for everybody and i
want to thank you
so much for being so gracious and
generous with your time
brian you're the best thank you so much
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you